ces roquettes sont les trophées d'une
contre-offensive précédente
un millier de roquettes elles étaient
juste là les Russes les ont abandonnés
alors nous les avons prises
dans cet atelier les Ukrainiens réparent
et adaptent toutes sortes d'armes
là c'est un lance-missiles on l'a
démonté et les gars on en fait le
premier modèle portatif
on a aussi fabriqué ce fusil mitrailleur
mobile des trucs comme ça avant la
guerre on faisait tous autre chose
certains installaient des panneaux
solaires d'autres élevaient des poissons
avec la guerre on a du s'adapter avec
nos mains et nos cerveaux
cela sont plus précis à une courte
distance que les versions d'usine
et je vous assure que tout ce qu'on
récupère chez les Russes on le retourne
on ne sait pas de rétention leur missile
on les leur renvoie
cette unité n'a pas de vrai
lance-missiligrade leur roquette il les
tirent depuis des pick-up puis à l'aide
de drone il vérifie la cible
cela fait 6 mois que cet atelier au
cycle des trophées aujourd'hui il
déménage
on s'installe plus près de la ligne de
front il faut qu'on soit le plus près
possible le front avance on doit suivre
nos gars
mais la ligne de front progresse
lentement
stéphane est inquiet
quand on fait prisonnier l'orgat et
qu'on parle avec eux j'ai l'impression
au fond de moi qu'encore un peu juste un
tout petit peu peut-être un mois encore
et la ligne de front va s'effondrer
peut-être que c'est juste de l'espoir
parce que quand on met trois jours à
prendre un tout petit village et puis
qu'on voit leur ligne de défense toutes
ces tranchées ces tunnels souterrains
entre les maisons
alors on comprend que ça ne va pas être
simple
pas simple du tout dans l'icône
mais pour eux laisser la Russie
contrôler ne serait-ce qu'une parcelle
de territoire ukrainien est impensable
alors ils avancent malgré tout